welcome to mlst today we are extremely
excited to have two distinguished guests
join us the first guest is Ellie Pavlik
she is an assistant professor of
computer science at Brown University and
a research scientist at Google AI her
work focuses on building better
computational models of natural language
semantics and pragmatics aiming to help
computers understand language the way
humans do our second guest the legendary
Raphael miliere is the 2020 Robert abert
presidential scholar in science and
Neuroscience in the Center for Science
and society and a lecturer in the
philosophy department at Columbia
University Raphael completed his defill
in Philosophy from the University of
Oxford where his work centered on
self-consciousness and his main
interests lie in the philosophy of
artificial intelligence cognitive
science and the mind
now this is an interesting experiment
for us we've decided to get these two
heavy weights uh just one-on-one having
a conversation with each other and we're
hosting it here on mlst they spoke about
compositionality and grounding
compositional generalization benchmarks
mechanistic understanding in language
models variable binding and Transformers
language and vision Models compositional
Behavior in humans compositional
reasoning and negation and language
models variable binding in reinforcement
learning and Transformers the difference
between instruction tuning and our lhf
and the benefits of rlhf referential
grounding and language models
and yeah the Chomsky skepticism of
course you know our friend Stephen
pianta dosey's paper inductive biases
and language learning language models in
different languages and indeed the
future of academic work in language
models
now the audio from Raphael in particular
wasn't as good as it could be I've done
my very best to process it and improve
it just to help folks follow along I've
kind of generated some subtitles there's
subtitles on Google were absolutely
rubbish and speech recognition
Technologies come along so far in the
last few years so I've generated some
better subtitles using another service
and I've superimposed it on the top I've
also superimposed some descriptive
titles on the top just to help you folks
follow along at home so anyway without
any further Ado I give you Ellie Pavlik
and Raphael pillier enjoy highly hello
Raphael hey how's it going I guess you
you talked to Tim before so maybe you
have a kind of more of a context of the
previous conversation that started this
one so you I'll let you decide where
we're beginning what the first topic is
yeah so we had a chat uh about a few a
few weeks or maybe half a girl ranked
him on the broadcast and we had to clean
shorts on these thoughts maybe you know
it's like somebody
as a discussion and
thank you to chat with you so it's info
that maybe some other topics we could
discuss would be compositional skin
problems that we both very interested in
that seems natural yeah yeah so
I don't know whether we should we should
try to to disagree more than actually do
because I think we were online
right I mean I also feel like for both
of them I'm like
I know what I currently think but I also
am pretty prepared to just have to reneg
in a couple of years and be like I was
wrong so I feel like I we we can see
both sides so we can definitely simulate
some disagree or we can we have to
disagree but we could argue both sides
of whichever issue
um I don't know where do you want to
start do you want to talk grounding or
do you want to talk compositionality I
think I have more uh immediate questions
with respect to competitionality so one
thing I was wondering is how do you see
um the progress on compositional
generalization benchmarks so just you
know forget for The Listener of yours
um what it's really hard to assess
whether large language models training
or language on a huge cobra
actually acquire the capacity to to
generalize completely properly because
you can never really know what's in the
training data with these models before
you can really know never really know
whether the the memorized structures and
so on so what strategies to use
synthetic data sets
um that's such that you know you train
them on a test set and Punishment set
and then when you test them the only way
that they can achieve a good cause right
generalizing perfectly
um and so there has been some the
initial results from some of these data
sets and benchmarks like scans cards and
others were a little bit mixed with lstm
performers and
lately there have been a lot of the
steady improvements constituted to
tweaks in the architecture and I
remember having this discussion with
with tal Vincent when August this uh
accomplishment Workshop before speaking
English
sub and one of the
one of the contentious points is whether
we could call these tweaks or whether
these are significant challenges and
that's always the the Crux of the debate
I think including also with things like
pulse velensity uh postalities approach
that
presentations is how much of a how much
of a hand engineered tweak you make in
the architecture to solve these
compositional organizationalization
problem and and how much do we need so I
was just wondering where you where you
stand on that
that's a super interesting I mean so
yeah so on the compositional
generalization test I mean
I probably have like an unsatisfying
Middle Ground opinion I'm curious where
your thoughts are so I think
I think we're both pretty interested in
the kind of mechanistic stuff right now
so I guess for the audience this is
um this idea that uh like this idea of
trying to kind of understand what the
models are doing
um kind of under the hood so when we
think about the I guess compositional
generalization tests it's like we have
some inputs what are the training like
what is the training model gets and then
what are the outputs that it produces
um and that's really the data that we're
facing our Claim about whether it's
compositional or not on
um and the kind of mechanistic or the
other approaches to try to
um
like characterize what actually is the
process it used to get from the inputs
the outputs I really like uh Chris Ola
who I think coined the term mechanistic
uses the phrase of kind of trying to
understand the source code of the model
so it's like you have
um you want that kind of
something like a kind of human
understandable description of the
algorithm that it's running under the
hood
um
and so
like I've just I've been super hung up
on that like I think all of my my
projects all of like what my students
are working on
are some flavor of that because to me I
think that the reason it's so I think
it's interesting but it also just feels
like the the questions about things like
compositionality are almost um stuck
right now without that level of
description so if we're just looking at
what are the inputs and what are the
outputs I just feel like we're
it's just going around in circles with
people like like we're not really making
progress on the issue there's kind of
people who are inclined to agree and
inclined to disagree
um
and so from my perspective like okay so
if we have
the model
that's doing this kind of I guess
quasi-generalization it's like
succeeding on some cases it's not
perfectly
compositionally generalizing in the kind
of really abstract case that those data
sets tend to be going for
um but it's doing something in between
and we're trying to figure out whether
that counts as
um
compositional or not it seems like that
just hinges on what it's actually doing
under the hood and how it's doing it
um so I guess I'm like
I'm like
basically like like neutral on or not
paying attention to compositional
generalization data sets right now and I
recognize like a very fair criticism and
I feel like when I've talked to people
like tall probably have this where it's
like you can't just sidestep the issue
it feels like being overly generous to
the neural networks right it's like
they're not doing that well and then you
like change the game a little bit right
you're like oh well that's not even the
metric we care about that's not really
what I would see as the goal it's just
like in the immediate term it seems like
first we want to characterize what's
happening under the hood and then we can
come back to those data sets and
understand them much more in depth and
then when we see how they're solving it
or not solving it we can like it gives
us a much more concrete thing to analyze
and try to ask whether that counts as
compositional or whether that's at all
human-like if that's what we care about
um like it like I guess to me it feels
like a dead end if we're not allowed to
comment on the procedure that happened
in between and right now we can't
in between inputs and outputs because we
just don't know what's happening there
so I don't know I guess that's my
current take on composition
data set system like now is not the
right time for them we'll come back to
them later
um which I recognize seems like a Dodge
but it's not meant as a Dodge it's like
basically we'll come back to this later
um yeah but I'm curious what what you
think about them yeah I mean I'm very
sympathetic to that view and as you know
that I'm super interested in the
mechanistic purposely
which is to choose to
looking at propositionality
and I guess in the background there is
lurks this this debate about whether
humans themselves have something like a
perfectly convolutional language of
thoughts or something else right
um absolutely and um and so perhaps you
know we might we might learn some things
about uh computations uh implementing a
human cognition by looking at these
imperfect uh computational systems
absolutely I mean I think that's that
would be really My Hope because like so
right now and this is a gross
oversimplification of where the two
viewpoints are but like the two really
concrete like uh
um kind of options on the table for like
what a system can be is like this pure
symbolic language of thought and that
the language of thought it would be
something like humans in their heads
have something like a Python program
language like a perfect kind of formal
system for reasoning over symbols in
this compositional way or it's like this
or like these associations these
idiomatic kind of just things back
together and like I think most people
would assume or something in between and
there's not a really good proposal for
what the in-between is right like
there's all kinds of ways of being in
between those two things and so I feel
like whatever we find in the neural
networks gives us some kind of concrete
proposal like here's an example of an
in-between it's not the language of
thought thing they're off also obviously
not just giant lookup tables right
they're doing something more than that
and so whatever they're doing in between
it's at least like a candidate for what
could be happening right that's pretty
exciting and it might not be the right
one but at least it's something because
I haven't seen like a really satisfying
candidate for what the in-between is
right I think a lot of the debate still
seems to kind of put these two Straw Men
up against each other
yeah I agree and
um I think some even some other people
who are back against this is
symbolic things with their thoughts
architecture
they're still faith that you need to
build into your connections model some
more explicit
compositional structure with these in
terms of product about these these
factors
that are neurofeminal that you can
combine with transported operations and
there are other Vector symbolic
activities like this that do it like
that and Mike Huang is always with with
this and I've talked before about this I
think you know he's open to the
possibility that perhaps Transformers
you know handling competition the way
Transformers handle leads might turn out
to be enough perhaps but my phone is
that if you if you build you know it's
kind of Hardcore into your uh Network
architecture or or you do some feature
engineering to have the the input
lectures the neurothermal that seems
just to be ad hoc to me right so you
need to specify what are the rules what
are the fillers and that's that seems
like an enclosible model for how
technician Works unless you want to say
that they are index academic Concepts
and we just you know I mean a lot of
people do yeah right that that's like a
a claim that I think a large fracture of
cognocides is very happy to say is the
case is that there's a inventory of
innate Atomic concept right
um
but but yes I agree I think maybe it's
the computer scientist or something
something about that is unsatisfying or
at least you want a story of where those
came from which still seems like you
somehow it needs to emerge or come from
data or come from some kind of pressure
other than just we got lucky and they
were there by Chance the right inventory
of Concepts I mean there's some deadline
between the core knowledge view that you
know there are some some basic huge
Concepts and the photo I am Zoo that's
all Atomic Concepts must be in it
because right yes which is yes
um right and it seems that if you if you
want to handle all compositionality with
this I've talked more than similar
factors or something along these lines
then
he
it's in fact you go in that direction
and what I'm excited about with
Transformers is that it looks like they
can do something that in my mind if you
look at mechanic the first military
researcher looks quite like variable
binding uh by reading and writing
information to subspaces of the main
embedic space and using that as a
virtual content reversible memory
but it's fuzzy right it's not just
implementing a classical symbolic
architecture because that's always the
charge that I think the the classicists
referring against the connection is that
oh if you're if your mother is working
well and if it's if it's a good model of
human behavior then uh presumably is
just implementing classical symbolic
architecture and it's right right right
right right right I mean almost I
where I'm uh teaching a class this
spring on language processing of humans
and machines and we were talking about
this question of um implementing a
classical architecture and it's actually
quite uh
hard to tell even in the historic
debates on this like what what people
are even claiming about this right like
there's like simultaneously claims that
like oh it'll like sure it can implement
it but also nothing it ever does would
ever count as an implementation like I
just can't even tell what the what
actually the consensus is but I agree I
think we'll get something that the ideal
is that when we look into the
Transformers we'll find something that
preserves the really necessary pieces of
it
um but is different enough to be
interesting I mean I don't know I guess
it in some ways if what we did if what
we ended up finding was something that
was identical to the classical
architecture that would be like I think
a huge win for a classical architecture
people right that the only way these
Transformers were able to solve it was
by learning to implement the thing they
said that you would need all along but I
think it's unlikely that we would find
that right like I don't really know
exactly how that would even work um so
we'll get something like this fuzzy
version
um
which which I think would just be
fascinating I mean I'm curious so the
variable binding stuff so I'm I'm
generally
take the position that the Transformers
these other logical networks will be
able to implement like these core kind
of symbolic operations we'll be able to
replicate this kind of behavior
um and that one would kind of dig under
the hood we'll be able to find these
clever implementations of these things
um but variable binding is one of these
things where I've actually really
struggled to find good evidence of it
um uh and and I guess particularly so in
language models it almost seems like you
have to say it's there
by
like by Fiat because of some of these um
the ability of the models to do this
compositional generalization stuff like
they they uh I think Tom McCoy had a
really cool paper where I was showing
that they could generate some like
syntactic structures that were
unattested in training so for something
like that you're like well I guess to do
that you would have to have something
like a abstract
filler and roll binding
um but especially when we've played
around the language and vision models
and maybe it's just that clip it kind of
sucks
um uh I guess clip is the one of the
pre-trained like image and text models
that kind of is trade to map um uh
images to to text captions but we've had
several projects of trying to show I
guess clip and then the image generation
models based on top of it like um Dolly
and estate things like that
um like we just can't get any evidence
that it's doing anything clever or
abstracting away from the um from the
structure so that's where we'll look for
stuff like a Red Cube in front of a blue
cube and then blue cube in front of a
Red Cube or things like the I guess the
famous on Twitter like um uh astronaut
riding a horse a horse riding an
astronaut
um and like even with really controlled
cases and doing it in large days that
like we just can't get it to do anything
that gives us any data to point to to be
like look it's doing okay
um but maybe it's just a clip problem
maybe clip just sucks I think it's I
think it's a good problem so that's
that's I wanted to talk about this
because you have this really interesting
paper about it and um I think we can't
generalize any funding about Vision
language models based on contrastive
learning and click to say language
models train Auto regressively uh there
is this recent paper from Stanford
configurably first author is really like
which which confirms my suspicions
basically the idea is that click to it
ends up treating text like just like a
bunch of words because in order to to
fulfill the contrasting learning
objectives bringing together the
captions and images that go together and
further away in the space the ones that
don't go together you don't need to
actually induce much about syntax right
just keywords is sufficient and and
generally also in the captions
themselves you don't have a ton of
information about say like their the
relative positioning of different
objects so how many of you know on
Snapchat you say they are key forks and
one and what knife or you just said we
played with sometimes or something in
the caption right right um right and if
you look at all the models like party
from Google or the imaginary models that
is a pretty trained as a text and query
is a pre-fin language model
you can actually do way better at things
like much better yeah yeah
and I I think that surprised me in
trying to do so we did the Red Cube blue
cube um kind of stuff because that's
like super abstract and it's easy to do
but one of my other students Charlie
lovering is working on a project with
some of the image generation models to
do to try to kind of more systematically
look at the you know horse riding an
astronaut kind of example and one thing
that struck me with it is just how um
like how uh not uniformly distributed
The World Is Right like it's just like
finding examples of relations like where
you want to have like argument one
relation argument two that can actually
exist in both directions and like that's
a thing that a human could visualize we
like it's really really hard to do like
we're restricted to a really simple set
of relations because we like spit out a
whole ton of things and tried flipping
the order and you're like yeah this
isn't a thing I could actually um
imagine or would expect a human to be
able to to
um realize in any kind of way and so
that I think getting it kind of
revisiting our assumptions about how
compositional humans are I think that's
like kind of relevant data to have is
like how often are we actually forced to
combine completely novel elements in a
purely abstract way without anything
that we can relate it to like what we
think we're our kind of working theory
for what the model is doing for these
kinds of things it's like if you ask for
a horse riding an astronaut it's like
finding the most similar thing it's seen
um right it's like well here's an
example of like a you know a teddy bear
riding a a puppy dog or something and
then morphs it into a horse ride like
some other type of thing and it's like
that's not actually an absurd model to
assume might be underlying some kind of
compositional behavior in humans too
right yeah it reminds me of the this
deep magnet paper with respect to
language models that finds all these
complex effects on reasoning where you
know when you test about syllogism
solver the Western selection tasks you
you get
um you get these effects that are
signature also found in humans where if
you're feeling the story or the task
with all details that could apply to
realize that it did much better right if
you just use it right it's like
far-fetched you know abstract examples
right right
yeah and that's that's been shown like I
know this is um I don't remember the
authors but there's pretty classic study
about the kind of logical syllogisms
right like if you ask people to reason
about these just like you know famous
modus ponens or whatever when you ask
them like a not a like people suck yeah
they don't know how to do it but if you
put it in realistic
real world scenario like you're at a
party you can have uh ice cream and cake
or whatever then people do totally fine
and I think it
um it wouldn't be surprising that we
might have these that we would have
evolved to be able to reason about
realistic scenes and not abstract ones
yeah and and the the I think this appeal
to be able to to reason over the most
the more abstract examples of including
with images come in those
objects inclusible ways and something
probably require
through training and people you know who
have felt children for example are
probably familiar with that so you kind
of lead to some prompt engineering as
you were to to get them to actually you
know drop certain Concepts so or to uh
you know teaching logic even to to
undergrads
um yeah you get a lot of resistance from
these contacts and to really find the
intuitions in the right way and I would
I wonder whether you know with the
astronauts uh running a horse examples
whether it would be interesting to try
that with with small children and see
whether you know whether they actually
do well at that desk yeah
yeah I mean I would have to assume they
would right so that's where like my
intuitions are strongly like but humans
are quite compositional like you would
you would have to assume that they would
know how to um
they wouldn't just draw horse riding or
if you asked for horse riding astronaut
they wouldn't just draw astronaut riding
a horse right they might like Giggle and
be like that's silly like horses don't
ride at something right but
um yeah I mean I guess so I guess some
counter examples to both of our
intuitions so that there's some of this
variable binding stuff but with the
image models and I'm kind of
like I'm willing to
um give the models a pass at least in
the immediate term while we figure out
what's going on because I'm like yeah I
think some of this
um perfectly abstract compositionality
might be like a tall order and not
something we would actually miss you but
the other thing that's always been weird
to me so like I'm channeling Roman
Feynman my colleague here who's like
much more of a language of thought
tradition
um and you know he'll say uh that you
know of course humans are like you know
better at like he's aware of all the
data that people aren't as good at
logical reasoning in some settings but
they can do this other sentence and
things like that but it's like that
doesn't undermine that humans have
logical capacities like we use negation
freely all the time like we don't really
struggle with that
um but the language models actually
still kind of suck at negation
um like it's pretty easy to just write
something
uh in a slightly odd way and get them to
ignore that you negated something I
think even fairly recently I guess I
haven't tried this in the past month so
maybe it's fixed but like
I asked something like
sgpt or chat GPT I think for like a
recipe that like uses tofu and
nutritional yeast but isn't vegetarian
or something like that and it just spits
out some vegetarian recipes or something
or you'd be like you know use sugar and
lemon but not a dessert and it's like
have you tried lemon bars and stuff so
it's like it just kind of ignores it
um
and that's weird to me because that
seems like for a language model doing a
language modeling task like that's
relevant like that's not this isn't like
a super trick out of distribution thing
um so that's kind of like I guess a
a thorn that like I feel like that's
where I say like I have a bit of a
caveat where I I wouldn't be surprised
if a couple years from now I'd have to
be like yeah I was wrong the models are
not at all like human-like or something
I'm hoping that's not the case but these
kind of data points are like yeah that's
it's frustrating how bad they are with
negation
um or other kind of basic things like
that
yeah I yeah I mean it it's always a
moving Target of course because people
you know maybe
four can can handle that first for
example but I agree it's it's definitely
very substantially
this failures as some
accomplishment yeah
yeah like we have some I guess so so on
one of these projects with Roman and
this undergrad we're working with Alyssa
um
we and this is just super frustrating
data for me although actually it is
getting better with the bigger models so
maybe it is one of these things but for
gpt3
um it was like we have this very basic
task that they had run on humans so you
say something like
um it like gives a little scenario and
then you say uh
you know the it's like some scenario
about scientists running experiments on
rats and it's like the scientists saw
that
um none of the rats liked the food or
something and then it's like now that
they knew that some of the rats liked
the food and they like did human reading
time and saw that people show to slow
down and were surprised by the word some
in that case because
um it's a blatant contradiction to what
was just said
um and when we use like gpt3 and predict
surprisal there's like no surprise
whatsoever no suggestion of any of being
at all bothered by the word some in that
context which is weird because that's
just a straight up language modeling
task it's just what is the probability
of this word in context which the human
data was very clearly like it's low and
the
um and the model was like it's fine and
then
but then we had we tried with gpt4 and
then the numbers
it looked better but it was kind of
messy because we can't get perplexities
out of gpd4 so you had to ask it to fill
in the blank
it is just
um the with GT3 we had the apis
APA as well yeah but it doesn't
we need to check okay yeah we need to
check last we checked we couldn't get
perplexities out like we had the API but
yeah
um okay yeah yeah yeah but yeah it's one
of these weird things yeah and so so
like maybe gpt4 is better but it wasn't
as clean of a comparison to the humans
and um and it was even for a model like
GT3 like it was surprising that it was
so bad at that and like I don't know so
I feel like there's a few of these data
points that are like uh this story isn't
a slam dunk like there's some of these
things that really should be easy for a
model with basic structure
um
you know yeah it's surprising to me
because there are you know this that is
spontaneous right that if it's way
smaller models
um Can exhibit the the right behavior in
terms of surprisal when you look at
things like subject verb agreement or
Fido Gap dependency is you know like
talented strengths on these and you know
a wide range of some tactics and exhibit
the same patterns as humans in terms of
being surprised when the syrup doesn't
back in the subject things like that
yeah even though you're throwing an
attractions of distractors to because
she's there right um so why is negation
right totally it seems much much simpler
right like it's not like if anything I
feel like negation plus these quantifier
terms like you could just enumerate a
table and say these things
can go together and can't go together
like it's I mean there's like a little
more semantic cushion around it you have
to know who the who's being modified or
whatever but like I'm quite sure models
can do all of that so I was very
surprised it might be just that it's a
really
infrequent thing in the training data in
the input but then you have this Poverty
of the stimulus argument that you have
to account for right is like
um I mean maybe it is that this kind of
entailment relation is just not frequent
on the internet but it is in kids input
or I you know I don't know or maybe it
is that the models are just not the
right models for this task I don't want
to believe that though I think there's
must be some other reason yeah yeah I
mean there's a state there by Will
Merrell that shows that and German
semantics can be induced by and
idealized an ideal language model uh on
synthetic data
up to a certain sentence length I think
in in real in in real world scenarios
there's only give it the size of GT3 I
think perfect contentment semantics
could only be induced for each of this
formal proof to send this to four words
um but but if you want perfect
absolutely you know perfect right right
you're exactly nowhere there's one
sometimes in the next and tell each
other off right which I don't know that
I believe in entailment right like I
just like there's it's like the logic
stuff you're like okay we can come up
with these like toy domains in which we
all agree about entailment but like
during my PhD I did a lot of work on
entailment and just trying to collect
entailment judgments on humans is a
nightmare right like they do not
behave to the point that you have like
that's what I feel like that was like a
switching point for me where I was like
okay maybe
I should accept that that we have to
trust them is entailed or not and that's
you idealized grossian speakers as well
humans yeah no no but it's it's
intriguing because it does suggest that
I mean you can learn something about the
time and semantics from distributional
information yeah even you know instead
of you know there was a sense like I'm
perfect right sense right so again why
is negation so hard is is yeah it's me
yeah yeah I guess I haven't seen a
really good study on just
what the distribution of negation in the
like in a model's training Corpus like
how is it used in what context because I
don't
um
yeah like it might just be that it's
actually it's just not distributed the
way we kind of think it's distributed it
just functions very differently in
written text in general
um yeah right like I do think that
perhaps kids would learn it like kids
get a very different input of negation
than what I would imagine is on the
internet right like I in academic
writing I use negation only in the most
convoluted ways like
like it with like these triple negations
that are right you know like while it is
not unreasonable to assume that such is
not the case right like that's the way I
would use negation I wouldn't say like
that's not a dog yeah like no one writes
that yeah and also it's interesting
because in in terms of the the text
that's actually generated language
models I don't think you know even
objective 3 in my experience you see
somehow sometimes they ignore the
negation as if they're trying to
maximize the relevance of every word uh
so if you mention if you say I want you
to give me recipes but not include
paprika
then see the word paprika and then
there's like I need to maximize the you
know yeah yeah right yeah and it might
be
I so when I was playing around with the
recipes and stuff it did seem to change
a lot I mean it was anecdotal but um
on the wording so like if you marked it
a lot more right like
um like if you said something like a
recipe with these things but include me
it does fine right so if you say not
vegetarian it gets confused also if
you'd say like and not vegetarian versus
but not vegetarian and like where you
put like
um like where you've whether you front
loaded or back loaded certain
information it made a difference and so
you could imagine there's these
distributional signals where it's like
when people are saying don't do this
thing they Market in a few ways right
they don't just like slip in the
negation but otherwise have the sentence
read exactly like it would in the
positive case
um like there's probably a reason we
have but as a conjunction and not and
right is just to like help emphasize so
that people don't miss that negation
piece of it right
um so like you could imagine something
like that that it's like the model has
very little incentive to emphasize the
negation unless there's other signals
that you really are right yeah so you
wouldn't like be deathly allergic to
paprika and then just like slip it in
give me a recipe for chicken paprikash
so so one other thing that this I've
just called The Sovereign
ERS and I can't exactly remember the
methods but uh the image that they found
that Transformers can't really do viable
binding unless it's by using the output
as an external memory and that relates
to some of the discussion that we had at
the conference that I cognized with Dave
Chinese and it's like films okay that's
where
um Nick shaveman are so much similar
name that you know the kinds of what he
calls non-content specific reasoning
that's Transformers can do yeah language
models can do
um he's always prompted by reasoning on
the output so using using
the generated work like the same China
step by step and you use the steps in
the generative steps the crutch uh to
solve problems and maybe that really
resources this paper recent paper you've
written structurality and subroutines I
remember yeah I haven't yet had a chance
to read that one but but uh I just
wanted to ask you because I was striking
to me that you you can do some things
zero shots with kind of language models
that seem to fly in the in face of that
kind of thing so for example with gp4 uh
you can you can tell it's behave like a
python shell
and then Define a function but with a
bunch of variables and then a little bit
later in the in the introduction just
you know call that function for specific
values yeah and and say you know and
because it's behaving like a python
Channel it just has to give the answer
with zero shot it's not able to do some
yeah whatever it just has to be three
and you can do this pretty reliably even
there's some failure modes but the fact
that you can do it that's Global
suggests to me that it has to be able to
internally uh right you know manipulate
the other variables
absolutely yeah I yeah I love that
example that you gave in the workshop
um so at this philosophy of deep
learning Workshop because you had that
like you had it behave like a python
shell and do this Fibonacci
sequence yes
the language model like when you just
ask the language model to predict or to
tell you the you know 700th Fibonacci
number it messed it up right yeah
super interesting and
yeah I guess the thing we like fight
with with these models is that they're
you know they're like we do know that
they have that they've trained over the
whole internet and so they've learned to
like kind of subspaces right and they're
like drawing from these different
domains and it's makes it really hard to
interact with them because they can
always from anthroporizing but they can
always pull this like oh sorry I didn't
understand the question game right like
I thought I was being my red itself but
it turns out you wanted me to be my New
York Times self or something like and it
could always pull that so it could be
like oh yeah no I know how but you have
to ask me to ask act like a python shell
because people on the internet don't
know the Fibonacci number right like and
this is a little bit of like
for the for the critics of large
language models this is a frustrating
game to play because like
like this is always a move that the
proponents of language models can make
is like oh you didn't ask it right like
it knows how but it
um which is really why I feel like the
mechanistic stuff is so important
because if we know more about it then
this becomes like less of it feels less
like you're sidestepping the criticism
so we can just say what actually
happened but I do think um that right
now that is the case right like it could
be that they
have the ability to bind variables and
do this stuff but just
they
have deemed that that's not the right
way to solve the task in the average
case or in a typical case like maybe
negation is not important for the
typical thing but if it if they're
acting as a python shell then of course
negation is important yeah and I'm
really interested in the role of our
relationship fine-tuning in iPhone 6s
because it looks like it's it's vast
improving of zero shot capacity to the
model and I think there's some of the
weapons that expands up you know
condensing the probability mass of uh
you know the distribution of over over
the next word
because it's it's essentially enabling
the bottle to to latch onto the right uh
test right right away right instead of
having to do this I mean still as I said
it still happens oh sorry I didn't get
your question right but if you ask a
question zero shot to valid gpt3 without
them on HF uh it will way more often
just have no clue what you're really
asking it and you have to like massage
the problems definitely totally yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I like to use I like
that um
uh openai recently re-released their
like the old school uh gpd3 because you
can see what a big difference even the
instruction tuning makes like
um my favorite is if you ask something
like write a report on uh the war in
Ukraine or something
um it'll like follow it up as though
it's like in an email and it'll be like
please include additional like details
on budgets and blah blah blah please get
it to me by Monday regards or some
people like rather than writing a report
it like gives you a list of other tasks
to do
um but yeah so there's clearly like
like the rhf clearly improves your
shower at least even instruction tuning
something I'm I don't know maybe you've
thought about this more I know we talked
about this like briefly before like just
I guess I'm I'm still getting my head
around what rlhf is or in particular how
it's
like
if it is profoundly different from other
types of training because I feel like in
some cases like I've heard a lot of
people kind of crediting our lhf as like
possibly like oh we have all these
problems with
um with launch language models but maybe
our lhf
alleviates them and I can never tell if
there's like a genuine feeling that it
does or if it's kind of a this is a new
kid on the Block and we're not sure so
to kind of
hedge or future proof whatever claims
we're making we add this caveat that's
like maybe our lhf uh alleviates it
um or maybe it's that like RL in general
RL is associated with like grounded and
maybe more cognitively plausible
learning in certain domains and so
people hear the RL part and think that
it's somehow better but I'm not quite
sure if RL is like rlhf is like deeply
different or if you could induce the
exact same behavior through something
more like an instruction tuning
setup
um like I genuinely don't know which of
those things is going on and I haven't
heard
uh like I know there are people trying
to come up with a fine-tuning variant
that otherwise behaves the same as RL or
lhf because rhf is unstable and people
don't like it when I brown has a lot of
people who work on RL and they look at
rlhf and they're like this isn't even
really RL
um because it's weird and it just seems
like you've kind of like folded more
language models on top of each other
um so so yeah I just I don't know how I
feel about it and
my gut is to be like no it's not special
it's like the same stuff in a new
package um but that's based on
absolutely nothing except bud so I don't
know yeah I mean I do share about it
using Google respect to the difference
between nhf and instruction tuning
because it seems you know if you look at
uh what people did with the Llama models
from the technology this is generated a
bunch of of you know input output pairs
with gp4 or something to create that
um
or
um yeah so yeah so that the of these
cameras uh so they they yeah so the
generative essentially an instruction
tuning
transcends and from models that have
been lifted from HF and then you
kind of get the benefits of Rolex Chef
right for free uh right or for 300 and
uh and so it seems that actually this
works pretty well all right so right so
maybe I don't know I mean it could be
um pure speculation but like it that
could be the case and our lhf is special
it could be that rlhf allows you to
optimize for a function that you can't
directly optimize for with next word
prediction but if you have an rlhf
trained model you can then distill that
function like the normal can then
directly something like that
um
I want to say the rohf doesn't even
optimize for a different or special or
function that like you could just take
the data you get from rlhf and just
use it differently and like fine tune on
it or something
um
I mean that must not be the case so like
I said I'm really purely speculating but
that I think that's the intuition that
I'm just like deeply wanting right now
is like is there something special going
on
um or is it just
we found a different way of getting
somewhere
um like we kind of stumbled upon it and
we could actually get the same effect
and and I feel like it matters it
matters from an engineer standpoint but
it also matters because I just hear our
lhf which I would like to talk to you
about that because you like mentioned it
in your grounding paper but like I've
heard it from a lot of people
um like uh F federenko had a paper on
kind of disassociating language and
thought and had all these different
criticisms of large language models and
the things they can't do and then at the
end it's like but maybe rohf solves all
of this and I was like whoa that's like
a huge but I don't know and so and I've
seen similar things elsewhere and so I
think to me I'm like
I'm just deeply curious if that's the
case like I I think I'm lacking that
intuition yeah no absolutely I mean
that's
the best way yeah
yeah
um so
just to forever for the audience uh the
so we've pretty much we wrote this paper
and essentially we said well people use
the notion of grounding in different
ways in the literature uh and none of
this goes back to Hornet's simple
grounding problem from the 1990
um next year in which he argues that
symbolic AI models
lack the capacity to have intrinsically
many forms additional art books
um
interpretation of of their
representations is provided externally
by the programmers so chrtlu for example
skip old school program that could
manipulate Lux in the blocks world uh if
you can link you can connect its
linguistic presentations to Virtual
objects but that connection is provided
as solid and externally by exclusive
programmers
um and the problem is how do we get
models that actually existing
grounded registrations of Legacy
guidance where here the key notion of
learning is referential so how do we get
representations that are actually making
reference to the the objects out there
in the world that they are bounds and
that problem has really emerged with
recent Financial models of various
worlds and so on and they've done a lot
of support back and so we we were trying
to
um
think about different Notions of running
several reference from notion of running
is the most important one and then say
well in light of that can we say that
language models training text away
achieve some form of referential
grounding and we do mean to narrow the
chat because we've basically the
argument is is going for the perhaps the
most plausible and convincing out to me
for the most people to something that's
a bit more speculative so with our link
Chef um so the permit essential is that
we with network prediction that's a
that's an intra-linguistic function
right so you're predicting the next work
instead of these pre-trained
um but that doesn't seem to give you
quite the the at least intuitively the
right kind of of uh normativity for our
form representations of of the worldly
reference of Music items uh such that
you could have the possibility of
misrepresenting something
um so in other words you don't have
anything to give you the right kind of
world involving function it's just you
know whether you're right or wrong about
the next token
um and I relate Chef on the other hand
because you get this explicit feedback
from humans including feedback about
truthfulness honesty you know the three
ages of rhf is helpfulness homelessness
and honestly rare too there's at least
one of these which is a number of
component that's about that's an
epistemility
or if you you know answering questions
about capitals of the world uh whether
you're rather wrong about the state of
the world when you say the Paris of
eclipse of France and so that seems to
be well involving in the right way but
then you know we had this conversation
uh a few weeks back in and
as you directly pointed out it seems
that
you know you could get that the right
kind of value public function without
this explicits feedback from humans and
we do actually think against the case so
um and going down from slightly less
consensual uh claim we think that you
can get in contact building you have a
fusion when you have a fusion form so
you have several examples of successful
shooting task if it's a future prompt on
worldly facts you also get these
explicits uh
feedback in the prompt about what's
right and wrong in the world and if
you're seeing complex learning as
inducing a function uh optimizing for a
function that's not just Network
prediction then you can also see that as
providing a well-developing function but
then if you go even further and say well
after all why not look at pre-training
and I thought there are some context
windows in there that will include
discussions of what the facts where in
order to do the next operation which is
the proximate function the model might
have to induce a more complicated
ultimate function that's about the real
world so I think that's where your
intuition is yeah it's taking you right
right yeah yeah I think exactly like and
and this is this yeah I love I mean I
love the paper and I like this idea of
the world involving functioning because
I think that is the um that's kind of
the intuition that
we all have right like there does seem
to be something that's not
uh like I think most people's gut
instinct is like next word prediction
over text isn't enough right and then
the challenge is figuring out like what
like where is the line like what is the
what it actually is the problem with it
right and that's um and that's where I'm
kind of stuck because I think my
like in my heart I kind of don't want
language model next word prediction tick
out like I don't want that to be the
whole thing
um
and then I just like and a lot of our
own work though we seem to be arguing
the app like I'm not quite sure where I
fall on this issue and so it's like yeah
you want something like this like this
world of function or something about the
learning mechanism right the learning
mechanism doesn't feel like enough
you're like no obviously people do more
right than predict the thing that
happens next but then like formalizing
what that difference is I just I haven't
been able to convince myself like I
haven't been able to come up with a
thing that I'm like yeah that's the
thing
I totally buy it like sometimes it gets
on this issue of like goals and I guess
this actually came up a bit in the
philosophy of deep learning debate like
you know and when I talk to a lot of
cognitive scientists and people who
don't like the next word patient
language well it's like yep you know
people have goals
but that feels like a weird
um
because you can say that the language
file has a goal and a goal is to predict
the next word and like so now are we
just like making a uh
judgment about what goals count as good
ones and not good ones there's a similar
yeah like this kind of um
having the person give the feedback who
is sufficiently tied to the world and
now it seems like we've like outsourced
the question of whether the model is
grounded to something about the trainer
and the goals of the train which maybe
actually is fine maybe philosophically
that's fine you're like to follow along
this causal chain you have to have kind
of
inherited from somebody who's also on
their causal chain so I I mean I don't
know because like yeah if you had like
somebody giving rohf feedback who is
like
um
intentionally misleading right or
or just confused and misinformed like
any of these types of things like I
don't know how that um
muddies the analysis of whether the
model is now World involved or grounded
right referentially grounded yeah
totally agree on the last book I think
if the whole argument hinges will solve
the of the assumption that the crowd
workers
actually you know know how to to run the
outputs or do it do it right to a large
extent right
and there's this and I guess this is a
classic philosophical qualm too right
like because we can
like humans could be totally wrong about
stuff right so like like science
progresses right so right now we might
be saying like oh the
um I forget what one of the classic
examples the
um like a lot of things about like
viruses and diseases right like we had
theories about what those different
diseases were
back in the day and then we learned
stuff and it's like an entirely new
thing now right but you wouldn't say
that the people historically had like an
ungrounded meaningless notion of that
thing
um right so we so like you need to
account for the fact that we could be
teaching the model something that is
ultimately wrong because we haven't
learned that in fact you know
the thing is there is a representations
a representation will account for the
fact that uh you can misrepresent things
right so
just because you have a
you know a linguistic uh like lexical
concept that is very functionally
grounded doesn't mean that this book
leaves
the possibility I have you know
something gone right in this
representing
right
so like thinking
yeah and I guess this is kind of it's
like
so if the model thinks that the capital
of France is Berlin quote thinks that
and it produces that as output
um I guess we need to differentiate
between the case where it's just wrong
and ungrounded and learning loose
associations versus it was quote
mistaken right but like that like
because I could not know the capital of
a city and like that it's true that I
don't have quite the right concept of
that thing but it's not the same as me
being a parrot that's just spitting out
exactly right and so I don't think we
quite quite right now I don't
know how we're drawing that line within
the models of them just producing wrong
stuff versus yeah I mean certainly with
uh I think perhaps things like rohf you
can draw that line potentially but with
pre-training I mean and I share your
intuition that
you know since it seems
uh you know we don't really want to draw
the line at early Chef it just it just
seems like the love hunting fruit
because that's what's going to cover
most people but uh and that's already
you know it's already controversial
statement to say length language and
text only can achieve the first HF right
totally but then we we would want the
further like you and uh but then It's
Tricky so
so here is the interesting that I have
uh I I've been maybe overly impressed by
these recent papers that look at income
tax learning and and and to show that
it's this one from Google and others
that show the same thing essentially
that they it then functionally
equivalents to right fine-tuning with
credit in this sense even though you're
not actually addressing your weights and
what's there tuning on what what's
what's the what's the doing gradient
descent virtually on is not Network
prediction it's whatever function is
inclusively specified by the future that
other types in the future problem right
um and so that really is the thing that
comes into me okay so so you could get
the work involving stuff from that and
if you get if you can get it add
different stab within complex learning
then presumably you could also get a
pre-training time if you say you have a
window a context window that's a bunch
of capital questions like what's a good
part of friends you know right yeah you
have some hugeot like stuff in the
training data that's presumably without
a lot of models when it's not at the
beginning but it's totally random but
when it starts learning when reaching
last at some point
right you know you might might get that
yeah yeah and I I think this is where
like I agree with that and I I agree
with kind of calling out our lhf as
possibly the a different point because
it's like it's a a good thing to ground
to as or not ground two two but
overloading the word ground it's a good
like uh data point right to use and then
trying to peel away like what is the
minimal thing like what about our lhf
gives it that and but like that's
exactly that logic you just laid out is
what I
I think I accept right now or feel
somewhat forced to accept right based on
this because you're like yeah that seems
correct
um
but then I have to go back to putting on
the hat of somebody somebody who does
not believe these language models
because and I and I think it is
important to point out that when we're
talking about language models being
grounded or having meaning it's not the
same as saying they are
uh conscious and intelligent right like
but sometimes but that's that's this
kind of elephant in the room where it's
like where are we going next and so I
think when people are looking at these
language models and they don't want to
acknowledge that they can be
referentially grounded because that
seems like a step along the way to
claiming that they are like human level
cognition in all of these other ways
um it's so deeply unsatisfying it's like
wait no like you've missed the point
like now we're saying that just having a
few examples during pre-training of
someone listing off countries who wrote
that down
in you know good faith just listing the
capitals of countries that's enough and
now the language law accounts even
though it's just doing next word
prediction over there like that seems
insane right and so I kind of like I
feel like I just go between these two
positions of being like
like right now based on everything I
feel kind of forced to accept like no
language models I would say they're
referentially grounded I can't find a
good case to make for why they're not
and at the same time I'm like do do we
really want to say that that seems
bizarre right like I was like yeah
but when we get our our hand forced by
this they kind of all of nothing's
thinking that you see sometimes in these
debates where it's like
um
at the high level stack either the
stochastic power saw or it's like human
like uh you know AGI with with you know
in understanding Consciousness
approaches whatever yeah yeah yeah
um and there's this huge you know uh
space in between possibilities that we
could explore when you look at different
capacities in the case by case basis and
saying that and then within each
capacity like grounding it's also a
spectrum right it's not like you know we
don't want to say you get a few examples
of of question answers about capitals
and then that's it you you have human
like refreshold running on everything
right you check that box now you're good
yeah yeah right so
um so so presumably you know you could
say well you know that that gets you you
know your foot on the ladder of
professional branding like in a tiny
tiny tiny domain and uh yeah yeah yeah
and and that's sales you know
theoretically interesting yeah
um right that said I mean there's
something that I think is really
interesting from your work on uh you
know isomorphisms between say in color
terms and and the color space and stuff
you've been working on the programming
that maybe suggests that sometimes when
you get a Toe Hold on grounding in a
specific domain you could Leverage The
isomorphism between language and the
world to give a little bit more for free
uh right right yeah right right you
definitely could
imagine that and I guess this is the
project that you and I started working
at together is the kind of what kind of
power of anal analogy reasoning do these
models have because yeah you could
imagine something like this like
with the toe hold and really strong
reasoning by analogy capability you
could get a lot
out of that but I I also agree I think
there's just this big Middle Ground like
it's not like you could
like
learning that the uh the meaning of the
capital cities or something shouldn't be
enough that now by reasoning by analogy
you can infer like everything the whole
world like that that seems
I I would if somebody could spell out a
mechanism feel which that would happen
sure but I can't imagine what that would
be yeah um yeah
yeah
I just I was
um I was going to make a complete uh
detour but I remembered we didn't talk
about the Chomsky stuff when we're
talking about oh yeah so I wanted to
hear your thoughts on that
um yeah I have some thoughts but I would
like to hear your thoughts on yeah yeah
so
um so just walk on thanks uh look Chum
skewed
writing about statistical models of
language learning for medicaids but
heuristically right on the records
saying as you would expect that his
totally skeptical Beacon and anything
whatsoever from language models about
human language acquisition Human
Condition in general
and he co-wrote this opens in New York
Times making decline
um even though he told me she would have
he signed on it but would have made it
possible a bit differently
because it goes to different directions
I think you know I have some Concepts
about how I would be a participle in a
lot of different actions I think he's
got this is more
his core part is simpler it's just
um
you know language models
that he actually makes analogy with the
Theory of physics that would say
anything goes and and he said that we're
going to be a good care of physics and
he's he's very impressed by this
particular paper that uh from Bowers
because I think Who let that looks at
learning supposedly impossible languages
and showing that they have salvation
models can learn such languages and
things that's that's then that's it all
runs on and forth yeah
um and then there's different I don't
see uh wrote this paper that say you
know taking completely opposite stunts
saying language models refute the whole
programming Linguistics
um
and I I mean actually
as as often in these discussions that's
the running thread but I I think there
are there's always room for positions
between the two streams yes uh so
I think there there was this interesting
interesting discussion that
um Challenger than others on Twitter
where there are two versions of the
covetical stimulus arguments that is
used to to justify the claim that there
is something like an index Universal
grammar in humans so there's a strong
version that Chomsky himself did defend
in the past and that some people still
defend on the neighboring very popular
like you know geometry grammar textbooks
which is
syntax is just unlearnable from data
period like middle model data will will
get you to learn synthetic structure
because uh having discovered cursive
Infinity productive system is not
something you can learn from detail
interesting yeah so so I think there is
a good argument and see it makes a good
argument for that being somewhere at
refuted by language protocols and a
discount in so far as they can you know
there is a lot of work showing that they
can induce synthetic structure uh
whether it is
it's the specific verb agreements uh
dependencies we can even decodes
pastries from those Nations so
um so that's a strong graphic but then
there is the the more in never mind more
reasonable developmental version which
is well the children
can do these constraintualizations on
certain synthetic phenomena and if you
think of dependencies from few examples
from these impoverished stimulus
um and it seems like this is hard to
come for if they don't have you know
strong in that device to make this
reductive inferences and one way that
you could have a strong industry bias
would be to have like image grammatical
strikes
and uh there are things the evidence
with language models is way less clear
and very well alternative so there there
is a little bit of so the problem being
that the larger models the giant ones
that actually q334 they went from all
the orders of magnitude more words 10
children do
um there are a few papers the one from
from genuine colleagues from 2041 and
there is more recent one for the office
training models with between 100 million
sorry 10 million and 100 million Words
which is uh what a child would get by
the age of six eight ten years old yeah
and they show that actually you can get
a lot of yeah learning paper with a
title like this it was like even when
trained on a normal amount of data
language models still replicate yeah
yeah and so and so what one of these
papers shows that what you get when you
train them you keep training them on x
square words these mostly he mostly
pretends to things like Common Sense
knowledge about the world and semantic
stuff but not so much the syntax stuff
uh maybe negation would be an exception
but uh yeah but that's how innocent yeah
um and there is this this also this
project and I'm really excited to see
the results of the baby LM Challenge
from yeah yeah yeah
um and so there's the same kind of
challenge they use this they created
this conference that's Conference of
child directed speech that actually
recorded from real real life uh child's
uh the kind of words that hear the
synthesis that here and there's a hard
version of The Challenge where you have
to train language Model A lot only 10
million words I think in a easier
version than 100 million words
and people will submit their
contributions and I think the results
will be more supportive August or
uh but yeah I think I think that kind of
projects could it might again
constrained
hypothesis in theoretical Linguistics
and maybe go against the weak version of
the properties and say look like maybe
you don't need
linguistic like syntactic in a knowledge
but even if that's the case I think
something you know
um
that doesn't mean that there is no
amount of of in its structural industry
bias whatsoever because after all you
know language models are not typically
arise they have electric license
Transformers found in the divisions uh
and even if these are not language
specific I think there's a key
difference before chimsky would say it
would say well you need this language
specific uh in knowledge uh there is a
sense in which the moderates empiricists
made software with the moderates
nativists to say there is some like
there are some inductive biases that not
that like General the domain General and
not uh language specific and we can be
happy with that so right
yeah that's a really yeah that's a
a great point and I think I
agree with that like I um
yeah I mean I also just in general
probably just a general rule of Sciences
like the putting something up as a
choice between two extremes is like
always detrimental right like and
sometimes it can prevent people from
working on the problem because they're
like afraid of pissing off half of the
field
um but yeah I so I had uh I like these
like one thing I was I'm thinking about
I always thought about was reading um
Steve's response is again the kind of
um just him on the mechanistic stuff
like to me it seems like the answer kind
of hinges I guess this is a different
version of the question but it seems
like a lot of it hinges on what the
model is doing internally to process
these
to process the language like whether it
represents something that looks like
Chomp skin syntax or not but I guess
this is a kind of a different question
so there's a there's the kind of what
you were describing which I think is
definitely like one of the important
ways to be thinking about this problem
from kind of a Linguistics perspective
which is like take the blank slate
language model and say how much data
does it need to learn because it
definitely a super significant finding
if you could replicate if like a
Transformer randomly initialized
Transformer trained on a realistic
amount of child directive speech learn
syntax like that's a huge finding right
um
there's also this kind of like take the
giant pre-trained language model
um
trained on way more data than a human
has but then you can kind of use that as
the starting point like that's the
innate structure that a human has right
which could be a ton of language
specific and uh I
syntactic structure and then that's kind
of what um and then from that point on
then it's quite uh efficient it's the
problem so that's kind of what my first
thought when I read Steve's paper is
like well we can't really say because we
don't know whether the model has solved
the language problem by learning some
like nice looking formal syntactic
abstract syntactic structure under the
hood or not although I think a lot of
data suggests that it has
um but I guess it's it's kind of a hard
question to answer because you can't do
something like
um you can't then take that as the
starting point of a language learner
because it's already learned a lot of
language like you would want some other
way of like inducing that structure but
then stripping out the ability to
actually generate language if you wanted
to try to replicate
like you would want to like find a way
of like pre-training the model getting
all the innate syntactic structure but
then somehow reinitializing a large part
of it so that
child would have to relearn and then use
that as to to ask whether what the
language while has learned is something
akin to the innate structure that
Chomsky would have wanted I also you
I mean I guess something you could do
because you mentioned like learning
unlearnable languages is like try to
transfer a pre-trained language model to
one of these
unlearnable languages because I like I
always think of
the I've been thinking of the
pre-trained language models as kind of
the
like that's whatever is endowed by
Evolution or something that's the
starting point yeah yeah
um right and so but yeah I I recognize
that it's kind of impossible to use as a
model of a pre-linguistic child because
it has way too much language to do any
interesting experiments on its language
learning but you could ask whether you
could transfer it to one of these
unlearnable languages and whether it
basically
needs to unlearn and relearn as
basically like if it can transfer too
well to one of these other languages
that I guess would be a data point
against
that structure being the kind of
structure that kids have born in whereas
if it like their models are very
powerful but what it might need to do is
basically unlearn everything and then
relearn the new language from scratch
um and then that would suggest that it's
like not yeah
it's not actually very learnable to the
models once they've been pre-trained
with this strong bias for other
structures yeah although you need to
show that uh humans that this this made
of languages are actually unloadable as
humans right and that's not to do
because you can try with adults and then
just like it helps you for them like a
second language but if you want to talk
about the first language uh if that's
how you say the name the the you know if
you think of free shredding as like
Evolution right
um and then you could say well whatever
is prescribing could be the index
structure of Chomsky and yeah so then
you would need to actually you know it's
an impossible experiment to do you need
to become very unethical if you have to
have it special
so because like what is the data that
those languages unlearnable is that no
language has the features that this
language has I think so they have this
weird yeah I I haven't done a deep dive
and I think it's very controversial so a
lot of people were convinced by that
paper uh really lust onto that as you
know hard evidence that we're going
right yeah I'm speaking out of my domain
but I so I would defer to someone who
studies this but my I see why it's
controversial right because there's like
perhaps lots of explanations for why
languages share common features other
than those are the only possible
features for the human mind to yeah yeah
interesting and there's also you know
there is some evidence I think you know
some people who are you not very
interesting Linguistics always come to
evidence of trust languages where it
seems that
um some of the features of generative
Karma seem to work better for us some
dominant languages than others
definitely interesting right for Rich
into it and then they started move
sometimes is to just add some kind of
thing to the generation of Grandma to
compensate for that but then it becomes
a little less elegant and yeah you know
yeah
yeah yeah yeah I mean I it's kind of an
or tangential point but I guess there
isn't as much work on these large
language models in other languages right
like I mean there there are multilingual
models and stuff but that's definitely
some data points that would be good to
know like we talk about Transformers
having some they do have inductive
biases and things like I don't know how
well they work for
other languages I've never seen a good
controlled experiment because just the
quantity and quality of data we have in
different languages is like
so varied that you just can't say
anything when the models are better or
worse
um but that definitely seems like from
the perspective of asking what do these
models mean for the Chomsky in program
or the universal grammar and stuff like
it seems like we need data on how they
work in
cross-lingually yeah there is this work
by Stephanie Chan goes from deepmind
that Lisa found the data distribution of
properties
not properties of the of the trading
data influences I think internet
starting and Transformers but so they
look at that we've made up data sets
that's different distribution of
distribution operations
and they find that the the typical
distribution of properties of languages
that seem to actually be there is work
stream that is you know there is
zif's robot lies across across basically
every human language and so it seems
that there's something in common in the
distributional properties of all human
languages that Transformers can latch on
yeah
interesting
huh
yeah
yeah luckily there's still lots of
stuff to think about like I feel like
sometimes it's like oh all the problems
are being solved these models keep
coming out doing all the tests and it's
like oh God no there's so many like I
think we still have careers ahead of us
that's good yeah
people freak out about uh the fact that
all the big bottles not being tracked by
industry and before it's taking away
from it yeah but I think all of the a
lot of the interesting problems actually
things you can only do on small models
anyway like mechanisms oh yeah
so in a way there is a nice division of
labor yeah I actually yeah I've us like
I work uh at Google 20 and I've said a
couple times like all my most
interesting projects are the ones that
brown because like I actually think the
small toy data things like that's where
I feel like I'm learning stuff I'm like
ah it makes sense that's how things work
like it's so exciting so yeah I'm I feel
good about
academic work on this stuff right now
let me listen optimistic Notes too yeah
yeah I think so uh that was that was
awesome this is fun
yeah we killed uh I guess I have my
timer going almost 75 minutes so it's
pretty impressive
all right then hi Tim